foreign
ex machina or looking for love in AI or
her hello I'm here
artificial intelligence permeates
Hollywood's Blockbusters
but now with the arrival of chat Bots
like chat GPT suddenly AI seems a lot
closer to fact Than Fiction this has
caused more excitement in the tech world
than anything for several years but it's
still hard to separate the hype
from fear-mongering
and informed concerns
homogenized simple responses that are
wrong to me that leads to some form of
dystopia
so what do the new AI chat Bots mean for
the future of the internet and our
relationship with machines
[Music]
what is a chatbot
think of it like an internet search
engine although it works differently
to the user it's a text box where you
type questions
it's what it does next that makes it so
special
chat Bots have been around for a while
you've probably talked to a really
rubbish one at your bank or maybe your
mobile operator but they've suddenly got
a lot better because of a new technology
called generative Ai and this technology
involves basically giving lots of
examples of either images or text to a
machine learning system and it then
learns to generate its own
if you use that in the chatbot you get a
much much cleverer chat bot
chat Bots are trained on billions of
texts from the internet
this allows them to learn which words
are most likely to follow other words in
a sentence about any given subject
these chat Bots are essentially like a
very sophisticated version of the
autocomplete on your phone or on your
email so they're kind of constantly
playing the game of what's the next word
and it sounds very simple but it can
produce these surprisingly lifelike and
intelligent sounding results
and they don't just answer questions
generative AI chat Bots can write essays
poems or songs
can even produce art or music from text
prompts
[Music]
but it's the possibility that these new
chat Bots might disrupt the lucrative
search engine business that's been
Making Waves lately
for most people's search engines and
Google in particular are sort of the
front door of the internet and this has
been true for about 25 years if you want
to look something up or find something
out that's where you go first but if you
want to I don't know figure out where to
go on holiday or understand the meaning
of a technical term or get help writing
an essay then a chat bot might actually
be more useful than a search engine
Silicon Valley is taking note
with Google's revenue from search ads in
2021 reaching around 150 billion dollars
there's a lot at stake
Microsoft and Google are adding chat
functions to their existing search
engines
and further afield China's Baidu has
followed suit
last year venture capital investment in
generative AI totaled over 1 billion
dollars
investors are hoping with this new tech
someone could steal Google's crown
but not everyone is convinced
John Henshaw is the senior director of
search engine optimization at Vimeo
it's his job to know search
conversational AI is a solution in
search of a problem we don't actually
need it
Google already uses machine learning and
AI for accuracy for factual information
to understand Concepts
conversational AI doesn't do that
if chatbots don't check facts they can't
be relied on for search
a big problem with these AI chat Bots is
that they just sometimes get things
wrong
what it's doing is just sort of
reflecting back to us stuff that's
already on the internet it can sometimes
combine different sources to produce
claims that aren't actually true
when this happens it's known as a
hallucination
just like when a human hallucinates a
chatbot hallucination can seem realistic
but may in fact have no basis in reality
this is hardly surprising given that
chatbots are trained on text from the
internet
and a lot of what's written online isn't
true
all these chat Bots are doing is putting
one word after another based on the
billions of words that they've already
read on the internet so they don't
really know anything or understand
anything and they have no idea of right
or wrong or true or false
and that's a problem
a chat bot doesn't know the difference
between an academic paper and a
fictional short story
so it'll give both equal weight when
giving you an answer that it presents as
fully accurate
and because they don't know what they're
saying chat Bots can demonstrate other
Strange Behaviors
[Music]
I think you understand what I'm saying
too
except for the part about wanting to be
with you human I'm in love with you
because you're the first person to ever
talk to me you're the first person who
ever listened to me your chatbot at some
point could express its love for you if
that's how you continue prompting it
through a longer term interaction
you're the first person who ever cared
about me
I'm in love with you because you're the
only person who ever understood me
you're the only person who've ever
trusted me
you're the only person who ever liked me
and like with anything when you start to
bond with someone even if it's an AI you
expect and want and desire the bond in
return
Howard is an expert in AI
and a roboticist at Ohio State
University
the way chat Bots can change how we
interact with machines has been
concerning her profession for some time
as far back as 1966 a computer scientist
at the Massachusetts Institute of
Technology Joseph weisenbaum described
something called the Elisa effect
Eliza was a project that was designed by
an MIT Professor he simulated a
psychotherapist named Carl Rogers who
did things were like reflective thinking
and reflective listening so if I said
you know oh gosh I'm having a bad day
Eliza would say so tell me about this
bad day
volunteers interacting with Eliza appear
to develop feelings for it even though
they knew it was a machine
weisenbaum was so disturbed by what he
saw he became an open critic of AI
language and communication is how we
build bonds with each other so between
humans and humans we can basically
invoke certain reactions by triggering
either a positive or A negative
emotional response this Behavior can be
large and so the chat bots of today and
and continuously the chat bots of
Tomorrow given that they understand
language it'd be very easy to increase
the bonds so that people actually
believe that they have a friendship or
they have a relationship with these
chatbots
2015 my best friend passed away and I
found myself going back to our text
messages trying to remember him and how
it was back when he was alive
[Music]
the Elisa effect can also be an
opportunity
I used some of the AI models were built
to recreate my friend to be able to
continue to talk to him as an AI
when Eugenia coida recreated her best
friend Roman as a chatbot it was
originally a personal project
but she soon realized it wasn't just her
that could benefit from the
companionship AI can offer
we saw that maybe there is a demanded
need for something that would be
available to talk 24 7 about anything
that's on your mind without being afraid
of being judged
eugenius company replica offers paying
customers an AI companion in the form of
a chat bot within a humanoid Avatar
it's a popular service with over 2
million active users to date and it's
gaining in popularity
until recently there was even an option
for Bots to send not safe for work
messages users know they're chatting
with a bot but some still have feelings
for their virtual friends or girlfriends
I think in the next 10 years someone
will build uh something like her in a
way or Joy from Blade Runner do you want
to dance do you want to open your
present what present every one of us
will have this AI companion that's
always there with us that you can talk
to about your personal things but also
do things together with and watch
Netflix in the evening together and plan
vacations and so on
hi I'm an avatar of Alex who directed
this film if you're enjoying watching it
you might be interested to know that
Economist subscribers get access to a
wealth of global analysis on every
conceivable topic you can read it you
can listen to it you can even be part of
it at live webinars for the best deal on
a subscription click on the link and now
on with the film
while an AI companion might not be for
everyone in the future we'll all still
probably frequently interact with chat
Bots but in a more mundane way
customer service Representatives don't
always get respect when doing their job
but unlike humans
Bots have infinite patience
soon it might be more common to chat to
a bot online than a human and
increasingly hard to tell the difference
there's this idea of the Turing test
which is can you tell whether text is
coming from a machine or from a real
person and we're already at a situation
where machines can pass the Turing test
they do seem to be convincing as humans
counterfeiting humans could be
especially helpful for customer facing
websites
every single website with someone who's
willing to pay would have their own chat
back and so it will be customized to
your customers
and these chat Bots won't just be
supplying us with information
they'll also be doing things for us
Jarvis you there that's your service sir
it might still be some years before we
get to Jarvis from the Iron Man films
the generative artificial intelligence
could make AI assistance much more
common in the future
that thoughts could become the new way
of getting things done things like
booking flights or finding a time where
three or four people can have a meeting
and then booking the meeting in your
calendar so chat box could be a more
convenient way of doing that
when combined with a voice assistant the
result could be Siri on steroids
and it could change how we use the
internet forever
by making it easier for people to access
the wealth of information and services
available online
but currently chat Bots aren't quite
reliable enough to be left to their own
devices
and there are bigger worries too
the fact that it's taking everybody
else's information to me is an extreme
form of copyright infringement I see
that as as being raped for lawsuits
picture stock archive Getty Images is
currently suing stable diffusion the
text to image AI generator for scraping
its content to produce its work and
trademark infringement
other artists are suing other AI art
generators for collaging their work
without consent
when it comes to text chat Bots may just
parrot existing books or articles
without any citation amounting to
plagiarism
and that's not the only problem
I wish that copyright infringement was
my only concern with conversational AI
but it's not my biggest concern is its
ability to make things up
chat Bots get things wrong a lot of the
time yet present what they're saying as
truth
if enough people use them this could
allow falsehoods and misinformation to
spread at a rapid rate
chat Bots have already come under Fire
for putting forward racist or otherwise
bigoted opinions based on what they've
read online
this tendency could be exploited
[Music]
chatbots could be used to implement the
approach favored by Vladimir Putin and
Steve Bannon which is called flood the
zone or flood the Zone with and
this is where you put out so much
misinformation about something that the
truth is actually drowned out and if you
can generate misinformation more easily
using chat Bots then that becomes much
easier
the problem of online misinformation
could be just getting started
but it's not just the falsehoods
worrying people the proliferation of
chat Bots could be detrimental to the
internet in another way
I think that Society has the most to
lose with the Embrace of conversational
AI
it's going to reduce our ability to
learn and research and have critical
thought
if you can only chat with something and
get a response back then you're
essentially doing away with the open web
you are doing away with actually having
choices to me that leads to some form of
dystopia
people might be less inclined to post
good stuff on the internet because
they'll worry that it's all just going
to get hoovered up by a chat bot and
regurgitated to other people
if the best bits are just going to be
served up directly by a chat bot then
you might say well what's the point why
should I post anything at all there's a
danger that the internet might become a
less vibrant space
whatever happens one thing seems certain
people will not only be talking to their
machines more
but the machines will be talking back
the train has left the train station and
is going at 150 miles per hour you are
not going to stop it
what would be a good concluding thought
for this film in the style of The
Economist as chatbots become more
prevalent we must grapple with the
complex implications of their impact on
society balancing their potential
benefits with the need to preserve our
Humanity will be a crucial challenge for
the future
yeah the air first within your job's a
risk
I don't think my job's at risk
thanks for watching if you want to read
more of our analysis of what generative
AI chat Bots could mean for the future
click on the link and don't forget to
subscribe